Farmers need to provide nutrients
like nitrogen for their crops to grow.
However, farmers often struggle to determine
the right amount of nitrogen for optimal plant growth.
And too much nitrogen may have unwanted side-effects
How can they be avoided?
Generally, nitrogen provided to plants
falls into two broad categories:
Organic and inorganic.
Inorganic nitrogen, also called mineral nitrogen, consists of small molecules,
whereas organic nitrogen is made up of larger and more complex molecules
found in things like compost, plant residues, or the soil itself.
When you supply inorganic nitrogen to soil,
it is easily available to plants - so the plants can use them fast.
Organic nitrogen, however, needs time
to break down into forms that plants can use.
Not all inorganic nitrogen gets used by plants immediately.
Since it is very mobile,
inorganic nitrogen that was not taken up can leave the soil
...and cause problems.
For example, too much nitrogen
can cause excessive algae growth, which can harm fish.
It can also lead to release of powerful ​greenhouse gases
called nitrous oxide or amonia.
Monitoring excessive nitrogen can prevent over-fertilization,
help farmers use fertilizers more effectively
and reduce pollution while still ensuring high yield.